[Music]  in keeping with the digital times  Parliament wants to bring the democratic  process online from a petition stewie  voting these aim to encourage public  participation and improve waning trust  in government any PS will call for  digital access for all EU citizen tired  of roaming charges the final piece of  the puzzle is in place the industry  committee will formalize an agreement  with member states that will mean the  end of these charges in the EU by the  summer the inquiry committee will  finalise findings and recommendations  arising from the car emissions scandal  they want more vigilance in detecting  fraud and stricter monitoring is  vehicles from cars in production to  those on the road the US continues to  require visas for citizens of Bulgaria  Croatia Cyprus Poland and Romania any PS  want an end to this and are calling for  full visa waiver reciprocity with the US  as soon as possible